britain is going through the biggest
rise in the cost of living for a
generation
and it's affecting millions of us i'd
say the past four months now
it's uh it's got really hard
i don't sleep i get about three or four
hours
soaring costs are causing some people to
make agonizing decisions
food for their families or fuel to heat
their homes how we're going to be able
to afford to pay gas bills and electric
bills when we're not making the money do
it
we've met those who say the rising cost
of living is seriously impacting their
mental health
i've literally been on suicidal thoughts
i'm just thinking i don't have money for
this
for some the stress is overwhelming
when the food runs out what i've got
when it gets even worse i just go hungry
for others
it's about survival it's just so hard
having to get up my video and put a
brave face on things when all i'm doing
on the inside is just falling apart
i don't want to be here anymore that
that's honestly how i feel i just i've
had enough life i can't take it anymore
i can't take cost of living anymore it's
just too expensive
ready one two three go
nathaniel where did yours go
[Laughter]
all right we'll try it again selena
walker and her family are finding new
ways to spend their time well the best
thing about it is you can come down with
the kids you don't have to pay for
anything even if you just make some
saunas and stuff it's just you're going
to freak out
clean you get a free water swimming pool
right here yeah it's a bit cold but it's
all right i wonder if the dolphins are
up there today
from the sky news center at 11. the
average cost of a full tank of petrols
hit 100 pounds for the first time
selena's finding the rising cost of
living more and more difficult to manage
yeah was one of the cheapest petrol
stations it was 174 and now it's and
then
180.
22 liters
i'll see five days
five days max petrol is really expensive
now and if it goes up anymore i think
we'll have to start using the bus
hi
where do you have your camera at here
because it does
six months ago selena was spending 25
pounds a week on gas and electric
now she's spending 40 pounds a week
that's an extra 800 pounds a year that
she can't afford we've always managed
and lived all right
until lately
the main thing i'm worried about now is
obviously christmas and especially if
that fuel goes up again and there's an
800 pound
i don't know what we're gonna do
hey hey you can't picture me
[Music]
my depression has been up and down where
i've literally like been on suicidal
like thoughts and i'm just thinking i
don't have money for this and i can't do
this and yeah get scared in case it goes
that cold that we don't have like the
gas or we can't pee the gas and then the
little ones are getting cold or they end
up holy
so that stresses us out as well
it's hard at the minute
do you feel that yeah
what does that feel like
it's like like i feel really heavy
like i can't breathe
[Music]
selena is in a unique position
she works as a support worker for mental
health concern a national charity which
provides specialist services on behalf
of the nhs
she sees this crisis from both sides
we've got a lot of people that are
coming back to the service that used to
be with us before so they're referring
themselves back a lot of them have got
back on their feet and been in a good
place got the job sorted everything out
and then they cost a living hit and
everyone's just fallen back down again
morning matthew is just selena calling
from together in a crisis you okay
matthew's been referred to the charity
because his anxiety has become more
severe
in the last few months rising bills have
put him under greater stress when was
the last time you've eaten anything
two days ago
all right
doing the dishes i'll just look at the
outside world and thinking i would love
to be out there
compared to what it used to be where i
used to have a life where i could go out
i used to talk about all my friends and
stuff like that
but now it just seems like i've got
nobody and
to feel all alone
and when you worry about money
and bills and
paying for food and stuff that must just
make your mental health uh it scented
right it sends it rocket and to be
honest it goes through the roof
and i'm just worrying where the next
meal is going to come from
matthew wants to show us how bad his
anxiety has become i'm getting a bit on
edge
the reason he's not eating is because he
can't leave the house
yeah i think this is as far as i'm going
to get at the minute
just feeling really dizzy and anxious
and you don't see shaking quite bad
around seven million people in britain
like matthew suffer from a panic
disorder that means they find it
difficult to go outside
it's just so hard
and that's why you have to choose
someone who's just like when i fail
like this all the time i just can't seem
to even do anything i just responded it
has ruined my life compared to what i
used to be where i used to be that happy
bubbly person just wanted to be out and
about
i wish i could get back to that but it's
so hard to
[Music]
figures show the cost of living crisis
led shoppers to tighten their belts last
month retail sales dipped by more than
one percent
a fifth of people on low incomes are up
to three times more likely to develop
mental health problems than wealthier
families
[Music]
we've just seen an awful rise in sort of
people just come into the service we're
all that emotional support for people we
try and help them sort of sort out the
finances get the right support put in
place contact councils food banks for
them and just try and get them figured
out and in the right place really
[Music]
but lately there's a lot more that we're
not able to do we've seen clients who
sort of
their suicidality has increased a lot
related to sort of the worries that
they've got about the future and not
being able to cope at the moment
hello hi susan it's just selena colin
from together in a crisis
we've received your referral form
susan is described as being in crisis
her mental health has declined to
worrying levels and she's reaching out
for
help feel like i'm struggling
financially because like i'm not getting
much work
i actually can't afford
to get the blinds it's just newspaper
for now
until i can afford it
despite being a full-time carer susie is
on low pay and after all of her bills
are paid she says there's hardly
anything left to live on
some days i go without food at all when
i'm at work i just i won't eat because i
haven't got the money to go and then buy
it
so what am i going to do how am i going
to live
here i meant to survive
i've lost
um
three and a half stone
since december
it's just so hard having to get up every
day and put a briefcase on things when
all i'm doing on the inside is just
falling apart i don't want to be here
anymore i don't understand how i feel i
just don't want to be hearing them i've
had enough life i can't take it anymore
i can't take
the right the cost of living anymore
it's just too expensive
i've even thought about suicide
quite a few times
i'll tell you about it scott
that's how law me mental health is
that's how law my mood is
billy joe has been assigned susie's case
and they arranged to meet in a local
park
i should be able to afford to be able to
live comfortably and get my house sorted
and i can't even afford to do that no
do you enjoy your work i love my work
you love your work so sort of care is
where you want to be i mean i just feel
like i'm constantly working to pay my
bills yeah and that's no kind of life i
shouldn't be living that life i feel
like i don't even know myself
yeah i don't i'm lost i don't know who i
am anymore what we can look at is
hopefully alleviating a little bit of
that pressure so you've got more time to
do those things that you want to do to
sort of
discover yourself again really sort of
figure out what you want what you want
to do
and how you're going to do it
more than half of households in the uk
have cut back on their energy use as a
result of the cost of living crisis
the government says it's providing eight
million of the most vulnerable
households with extra support this year
and all domestic electricity customers
will receive at least 400 pounds
the government also says it'll spend an
additional 2.3 billion pounds a year by
2024 on mental health services we're
delivering things at a grassroot level
we're delivering things with the people
on the street who actually need that
help today and unfortunately it takes a
long time for that funding to reach us
if at all if we do not see
funding
increasing in line with the demand that
we are seeing and the increased number
of people accessing our services and how
complex those people are then yes people
will die
[Music]
the government says it'll help ease the
pain of rising costs with a package of
measures
but will it be enough
it's bad enough as it is now but once
you get to the winter months there's
going to be a lot of hungry and cold
people out there
can you afford to live
not really
it's really hard at the moment really is
people keep saying not to suit you it's
not a bad life it's a bad day you know
it's not about life
it's not a bad day it's about life
when people say that to me i'm like live
in my shoes live my life then tell me
it's a bad day
because i'll have bad days 24 7
for the past six months
it's been like this
i just
i've been trying to cling on to life see
i've done well so far but i'm like
on the edge right on the edge
[Music]
if you are affected by any of the issues
raised in nyx reporting you can contact
the samaritans on 116 123 or email joe
samaritans.org